c'est tiré du petit sauvage d'alexandre
jardin c'est réalisé par ifop jardin ya
jean hugues anglade qui est séduisant
malheur top craquons quoi je veux dire
ah oui c'est fait pour sitting gonzesses
moi j'ai hong kong là bas vous pouvez
pas stock raconte qu'il a il sourit les
mêmes attal souris dans votre film je
suis homme extraordinaire parce que yvan
attal j'avais vu sourire de ma vie il
envoie souris deux fois et dit la même
chose de vous
alors tout le monde est boosté enfin les
deux sont boostés par hélène de
fougerolles que je combats pour qu'elle
tourne pas plus et hélène de fougerolles
honnêtement lorsqu'elle est rentrée dans
mon bureau je me suis dit
je suis mais pourquoi je suis pourquoi
l'a pas fait ça déjà trente films bah
oui c'est pas ça c'est
l'alcoolisme et voilà ça me semble
évident que ça va être elle tourne avec
beineix là elle commence sachs a repris
le même casting puisque il a repris en
garde et hélène de fougerolles et alors
parce que je veux dissiper la jdz est
plutôt du côté anglade que du côté attar
s'est passé c'est qu'il ya julie
depardieu très justement j'ai cru que tu
es samy naceri je me suis dit c'est pas
possible
elle a commencé à me caresser à ben
julie au courant je me suis dit c'est
bizarre qu'est ce qui se passe c'est
sami qu'il faut caresser enfin mais moi
je veux bien accepter les caresses
mellon mais changer mais changer
immédiatement de place à l'arrivée comme
ça ce sera juste un toit vous caresser
il faut un contact à l'or fin
alors lorsqu'on voit un an dont
vous faites vos affaires entre fait nos
affaires serge tu laisses une caméra sûr
comme ça on verra ce qui sait ce qui
s'est passé tu laisses une caméra
diverger sur recherche s'il te plaît
donc il ya votre intérêt alexandre
iata gré à bout elles exactement le
genre de comportement qui a envie que
mon film déclenché
j'ai envie qu'on sorte des salles avec
des encours des
chalets d'iraty alexandre est un petit
peu cheap amené laurent ruquier à
s'intéresser voire plus si affinités
julie depardieu je pense qu'il aura
vraiment servi à quelque chose bonjour
écoute
elle est formidable et voilà c'est rare
ils ne pouvaient seringues et comme ça
je veux dire voilà une émission j'ai
vraiment c'est génial suivent émission
qui fera plaisir à sa mère lors on ne
dit pas gonzesses une forme une femme et
voilà avec témoin l'a conçu
voilà
alors ce qu'on voit dans votre film
vous êtes complètement jardini cela là
vous êtes un vrai jardine nice
comportent comment graver dans le
dense qu'on va densifier votre votre
intérêt pour l'éducation nationale comme
j'ai fait sciences po
ses passions le doigt vous allez payer
aux pauvres vous vouliez en fait vous
occupez de réforme de l'éducation
nationale c'est pas un truc très simple
sur un film qui par l'éducation
nationale au delà de donner envie aux
questions ça parle de l'éducation
d'ailleurs je lance un appel à jack lang
si vous avez besoin d'un conseiller jack
c'est vrai vous étiez vraiment fait à
l'ecofin l'école à sciences po vous
étiez intéressé par le problème
d'éducation nationale oui ben oui parce
que parce que les vrais questions
politiques m'intéresse voilà ça devait
être un homme de gouvernement en fait
non l'homme d'état non ce qui me faisait
rêver et ce qui me fait toujours rêver
c'est
c'est c'est de faire en sorte de vivre
dans une société génial et c'est vrai
que pour moi le fait de faire un film
sur le monde de l'éducation nationale
avec le prof c'est ça va dans la même
logique voulait changer la société oui
et c'est ce qu'on est en train de faire
en ce moment vu une association de
regards qui prouve que c'est pas du
pipeau qui s'appelle lire et faire lire
il ya déjà 100 écrivains qui sont mêlé à
ça c'est quoi le but de cet assaut s'est
très simple c'est de faire en sorte
qu'ils plus un gamin qui entrent en
sixième en france sans savoir lire et
comment en transmettant par le plaisir
il n'y a pas d'autre solution que de
transmettre le plaisir et on a trouvé
une solution très simple qui est
d'étendre à tous le pays une initiative
qui a fonctionné à brest pendant quinze
ans ça consiste à faire venir les
retraités dans les écoles primaires
oui c'est moi j'ai entendu parler de ça
je fais pas que c'était ça ou rien il
n'en est alors on a déjà douze
départements qui ont démarré après
pâques on en aura 30 et on aura le la
grosse majorité des départements
français qui vont démarrer à la rentrée
et on fait sa place pour les jeunes dans
les écoles si en plus on email
non mais simplement je profite d'être là
pour dire que si vous il ya des instits
qui ne regarde pas le des directeurs
d'école il faut qu'ils appellent et s'il
ya des retraités qui veulent faire ça
dans leur commune ou d'un quartier il ya
un numéro de téléphone voici un numéro
de claude allègre qui va s'afficher
non c'est le 0 825 832 833 mais sans
comparer à 832 800 magie de la
télévision et finalement si on veut
résumer un peu simplement c'est que vous
êtes vraiment un mi chemin entre votre
grand père qui était proche de l'êta
était proche du pouvoir avec toutes ces
idées là est proche de votre père qui se
préoccuper plutôt des femmes vous êtes
un plus un parfait mix entre votre père
et votre grand père quoi suis je suis
une sorte d'hybride mais c'est
extraordinaire la famille de jardin mais
comme ils sont tous écrivains chaque
enfant écrit sur le
sur son père donc votre grand votre père
a écrit pascal jardin a écrit sur son
père donc un formidable la gare devant
la gare à 9 ans hénin jaune 1 donc votre
père a écrit pascal jardin écrit sur son
père jean jardin et vous alexandre
jardin vous avez écrit un livre le
zubial sur votre père pascal jardin donc
chacun écrit comme ça votre fils qui
aura pesé les enfants trois filles et un
garçon maintenant 33 mais qu ils
s'appellent que ryanair qui va agir
suivant était sûr j'espère enfin parce
que je jouais
10 points alors votre grand père était
directeur du cabinet de pierre laval à
vichy
il n'a pas une mauvaise image jeudi
rebond papon ça a été la ruée ça a été
la lie y a pas que lui d'ailleurs mais
votre grand père il passe un peu à la
hâte dans tout ça pourquoi parce qu'il
avait joué le double jeu pendant la
guerre parce qu'il avait pris soin de
sauver des juifs parce que les gens de
l'ombre vont toujours des vies un peu
plus compliqué ouais et que la réalité
des mais moi ça me pose quand même un
très gros problème ouais malgré ça ça
vous embête d'en parler non non c'est
pas ça non ça me pose un point après
noël dans la vie oui un problème dans la
vie ouais qu'est ce qu'il ya ah ben
voilà alors julie c'est moi qui prends
c'est comme un décor elle aussi ya
toujours un coupable général à la voilà
le futur sont les mêmes que ça c'était
pareil que c'est légal a voulu cette
année effigie vie est extraordinaire
c'est pour la fois jouer comme ça et moi
je ne fais pas des ses manies facile je
vous caresse le coût d'une absence hier
vous avez votre col de 2 de baisse qui
est tout sens dessus dessous la scea
premier avec l'accord
alors notre père romancier scénariste
voir le nombre de films qu'il a fait
même pas le temps de les citer il a fait
parmi des scénarii où les dialogues
parmi les plus grands films français
votre père une centaine de films et 56e
certaines années il a dû écrire jusqu'à
17 films il vivait une vie assez
particulière il est mort quand vous
aviez 15 ans et vous dites il n'est pas
vraiment mort du cancer il est mort
d'avoir vécu toujours à l'extrême on
peut pas impunément et mais sans femmes
faire sans fil perdre 100 millions et
roulait toujours à cent à l'heure
une vie
ça vous fait fantasmer vous way l'homme
pressé ça m'a toujours fait fantasmer
moi ben effectivement il a vécu comme ça
c'est à dire que chaque seconde a été
d'une intensité exceptionnelle moi j'ai
vécu 15 ans et des morts lorsque j'avais
15 ans et chaque seconde a été
a été brûlée avec une obsession c'était
d'essayer aussi de me transmettre une
certaine idée de l'amour et c'est vrai
que là la première fois que j'ai ramené
une fille à la maison il m'a dit il m'a
vu en larmes parce que elle est repartie
en train pour la yougoslavie et il m'a
dit écoute mon chéri
on saute dans l'avion on risque le train
on arrive en yougoslavie avant que le
train arrive demain matin tu seras sur
le quai elle te trouver là tu deviens
inoubliable et les filles se
souviendront de toi dans sa famille
pendant qu'un génération on l'a sacrée
personnes non laffoley effet on l'a fait
on a fait on a rattrapé le train dans la
nuit on est arrivé à lubjana
pays et j'étais sur le quai lui était
planqué
derrière journal un peu plus loin et de
la fille moi j'avais 13 ans elle en
avait 18 elle a sauté du train il a
sauté dans les bras d'un type qu'on
avait
là je me suis planqué derrière le poteau
je suis devenu tout gris on s'est
regardés avec mon père il a blessé
journal est reparti
mais c'est un personnage je vais pas
raconter le zubial parce que finalement
tout le monde peut acheter faut lire le
bouquin chaque année ces femmes et ces
maîtresses se retrouva à sainte-clotilde
quand même extraordinaire quand il
s'adresse votre fantasme cup à votre
mort pendant 15 ans le sort tout ya un
vrai quand il qu'un tueur roulait ma
femme est là à les croire
quand il roulait sur la route il prenait
toujours le panneaux autres directions
ils envoyaient cinq autres os par jour à
une prostituée d'hôtel qui était son
directeur littéraire v6 d'exception
directeur littéraire est alors pire que
tout il mettait des phrases du général
de gaulle parce qu'il a écrit les
dialogues d'angélique il mettait des
phrases du général de gaulle dans dans
la dans la bouche d'angélique enfin
c'est vraiment un type moi ça m'a donné
mais je l'avais lu le bouquin qu'on
s'était pas donné envie de le relire un
homme lit même librement alors vous
dites la fin du bouquin d'ailleurs et ce
sera la dernière phrase ta mort enfin
cessé de nous séparer
bien alors on va faire un petit anti
portrait chinois ne bouge pas julie
pendant le single
ce
qui démarre pando
c'est vrai oui allez-y
c'est une émission libris il n'y a pas
de problème à aller faire pipi drap
comme ça on sera tous combien de
tranchant et diac
mais modeste avec ça bien alors
attention en se concentrant j'espère que
julie depardieu n'étant plus là sans
gilet qui avait dû sera un petit peu
plus concentré mon cher ruquier
donc vous connaissez le portrait chinois
si j'étais vous et vous vous là vous ne
répondez pas voulu c'est répondre jardin
si j'étais une fleur je serai à myosotis
tout ça ça c'est l'anti portrait chinois
donc évidemment c'est pas de fleurs dont
je vais vous parler si vous étiez un
défaut
je serais un homme
si vous étiez une injure
si j'étais une injure je serai une
il y à un cas d'injures extraordinaire
qui est devenu un mot positif des
[ __ ] oui oui c'est vrai c'est bien
que les [ __ ] aujourd'hui c'est
aujourd'hui c'est magnifique c'est bien
qu'ils donnent du mal pour faire partie
des [ __ ] c'est comme l'académie
française pour faire partie des [ __ ]
c'est un long et les nageurs qui ne va
car elle karen mulder a mis des années
pour être accepté par les [ __ ] être
acceptée par les [ __ ] aujourd'hui
c'est l'académie française il faut
rendre des visites
si vous étiez un collabo
jeu
non qua non j'ai pas envie d'être un que
le mot si vous étiez une maladie
si j'étais une maladie je serai je serai
une maladie très grave producteur de
cinéma c'était c'est à dire ces fous
furieux qui à un moment donné paris sur
les rêves des autres déjà parier sur les
chiens séduire des mangues way sur ceux
des autres si vous étiez un accident
mais
plutôt un coup de foudre voilà je vous
dis une perversion
les seules vraies pervers qui me
plaisent je pense à ces gens très
manipulateur je pense à talleyrand ou 1
où
ces hommes politiques féroce terribles
qui ont été des pervers
la perversion me va lorsqu'elle va pour
défendre l'intérêt général
la raison d'état oui et et le sens de
l'intérêt général si vous étiez une
guerre une guerre scolaire un diktat une
guerre scolaire agitateurs
un dictateur si j'étais un dictateur jeu
charlie chaplin ou ou un autre encore
plus inoffensif jacques chirac sait déjà
que si c'est parce que chirac en
dictateur ils seront pas prêts mais je
ne sais quoi si vous étiez un vice
je sais bien mais c'est
si j'étais un vice je crois que je serai
thierry ardisson or parce que faire un
anti portrait comme ça ouais s'adressant
à moi ouais ça c'est pervers mais sa
mort c'est un petit portrait chinois il
hommage très bien que les écrivains j'ai
remarqué sur ça quand j'ai des écrivains
je leur fais ça parce que ce métier une
arme
une norme
un clitoris est ce que ses larmes quand
même qui c'est la seule crèche ont plus
fait la loi sur la terre voilà un
clitoris
d'après lui oui ah ça fait la loi sur la
terre si vous étiez un supplice
sur le tunnel parce que quand on veut
pressé sur la détente
à noter une petite justes efficaces
un supplice un supplice
1les vrai supplice ces
scellés rêve d'enfant tu qu'on n'arrive
pas à quitter quand ces trucs qui nous
lâchent pas
eu une panne
panne une panne une panne je dirais le
le bug de l'an 2000 on est beaucoup
moins il y en a eu un ouais mais cette
fois qu'il est réussi si vous étiez un
[ __ ]
pour échanger pas vous parce qu'on me
l'a déjà répandu 500 fois non non non si
j'étais un seul
ça me ferait des vacances parce que
honnêtement ça doit être jouissif
parfois je me suis dit mais qu'est ce
que ça fait de se lâcher complètement
parce qu'on a on est tous traversé quand
même par des instincts un peu bas et
puis quand même on retient qui est
honnêtement je me suis jamais vraiment
lâché
pour me comporter en france elle ou il
doit y avoir une forme de jouissance
l'aide sûrement je vous étiez un poison
l'illettrisme
un assassin c'est peut-être le pire des
poisons je vous ai tient à ça ça je
serai
je crois que je serai une si j'étais un
assassin je crois que ce serait une
erreur judiciaire je crois je suis né à
sion si vous étiez une torture
si j'étais une torture je serai je serai
hélène de fougerolles là je rendrai fous
les hommes et je me donnerai pas
si vous étiez une mort si j'étais une
mort je crois que je serai une mort
choisie mais mais comme j'ai l'intention
de mourir ou de très vieux pas comme mon
père il m'a un peu de temps pour pour
terminer la réponse très bien merci